Sky News understands that football fans
will no longer be allowed to buy alcohol
around World Cup stadiums this very late
decision comes ahead of the opening game
in Qatar on Sunday Qatar had originally
ordered Budweiser stands to be less
prominent but now appears alcohol will
not be sold at all we can now speak to
our Sports correspondent Rob Harris
who's in Doha Rob crikey this is going
to be a pretty joyless occasion if the
fans can't get a pint at the footy
yeah fans will still be able to get
drinks around delhar in Hotel Bars and
in fan zones but it will be at stadiums
that fans won't be able to buy a drink
there had been a decision to only allow
alcohol to be sold in the perimeter of
the stadium so not inside the stadium
Bowl itself and for limited periods
three hours before kickoff and an hour
after kickoff but now this very late
decision what two days before the
opening game of the tournament Qatar
against Ecuador top level talks have led
to the decision to ban alcohol
completely from being sold to fans uh
Budweiser the official FIFA World Cup
sponsor one of the significant sources
of revenue the sponsorship at FIFA
paying what around 60 plus million
pounds Over a four-year period for the
sponsorship well now Budweiser won't
have their alcoholic products sold
around stadiums and what I'm being told
from a source familiar with the
discussions is that they thought
actually at this point not allowing
alcohol to be sold will create a more
enjoyable environment and
the Qatari officials in particular have
seen scenes of unrest particularly even
at Wembley at Euro 2020 with the way
alcohol can lead to disorder and that
has created this late concern because it
was at the start of the week we're
actually hearing about how Budweiser had
to move its beer stores to less
prominent positions at stadiums because
they wanted to keep it away from where
families might be buying things like
merchandise which just showed how
sensitive this issue is because for the
Dozen Years since Qatar bid for this
world cup and has been preparing for the
tournament one of those concerns had
been the availability of alcohol in this
conservative Muslim nation and although
it's not freely available in shops in
fact they're just one shot that
foreigners can buy it in it have been
available in bars and Qatar reorganizers
had been in indicating that you would be
able to buy drink at World Cup stadiums
but it just shows the sensitivity it's
so close to kickoff that they've taken
this decision the World Cup Supreme
committee and FIFA together to no longer
have the drink available but potentially
and how will fans react to this there
could still be alcohol available in the
corporate Hospitality areas where those
luxury seats are so
this will be you know an issue that fans
will be
greeted with as they arrive here into
Qatar ahead of the opening England
playing around on Monday Wales playing
the United States in their first games
too and we awaits here yet officially
from FIFA and the World Cup organizers
this is something Sky News has
understood and we're also yet to hear
from Budweiser themselves well quite Rob
I mean on the face of it this looks like
a massive breach of contract between the
World Cup organizers and one of their
key sponsors
yeah and you know this is something that
we've understood that this decision has
come unexpectedly we have thought it had
been settled a few weeks ago that they'd
settled on these certain time zones time
periods when alcohol could be sold
around stadiums and we have seen in the
past before in Russia in 2018 in Brazil
in 2014 that FIFA has had to work with
local authorities to get the laws
relaxed to allow alcohol to be sold
because let's remember this is not a
situation unique to Qatar where there
can be alcohol restrictions related to
football I remember being at Euro 2016
and France and disorder there and unrest
led to entire cities having alcohol
banned from being sold in it to try to
prevent unrest in Scotland you still
can't buy any alcohol at football of
course in English football in the
Premier League in particular you can
only buy it away from sight of the pitch
so there are alcohol restrictions around
the world but Budweiser had been
receiving assurances over many years as
a top level FIFA sponsor that there
would be an accommodation that would see
alcohol sold at football stadiums here
for the first time in Qatar because I
say it is normally only sold in limited
places and it means as Qatar and FIFA
want us to be focusing on the football
ahead of this first Middle East World
Cup Opening it's still many of those
sort of side issues that are dominating
the discussion and the uncertainty as we
approach the opening on Sunday